hey good humans just wanna take a moment
say thank you everyone who's bought a
human good face mask with your help and
with a partnership of masks euros we've
been able to doing over 3,000 medical
grade masks to local hospitals and
health care workers and we actually have
a special guest wants to say thank you
herself hi my name is Johanna Dilara I'm
an RN here at Kaiser West LA in Los
Angeles I want to give the biggest thank
you and shout out to mask heroes and
Jubilee for your very generous donation
of math we are so so appreciative words
cannot describe how wonderful it is to
be supported and loved by our community
huh alright but no further ado please
enjoy it yes
two different times we didn't speak
there was a time where I was convinced
that if I had a wedding he wouldn't show
up if I had a kid he wouldn't care to be
able to have that conversation has
really been a huge blessing man
[Music]
for the last seven years I've been
without a guide not because he passed
but because of the unfortunate event
that we have to just part ways with him
my father and I did not meet for the
first time until I was eight and what
was that like when you met your father
terrifying nervous exciting everything
that I wanted and was scared to see at
the same time have an unusual
relationship my son was on the other
side of the country most of our
existence together so parenting from
afar I think one of the major
misconceptions is that like black kids
don't have great dads I grew up with a
great father because I have a seven and
a half year old and we adopted him at
birth I view my responsibility is to
just give him as much experience and as
much insight to the varieties of the
world so he has the tools necessary to
enjoy life
[Music]
my name is Charles I live in Fullerton
and I am a musician my name is angel
I'm from the Inland Empire and I'm a
worship leader my name is Daniel and
from the valley and I make things pretty
my name is Steven I'm from Stockton I'm
a warehouse worker and I have my own
clothing brand my name is Tim I live in
Fullerton and I'm in Auto Parts sales
can I get my father's on the left and my
son's on the right if you agree with the
prompt you'll come forward I am closer
to my mother than my father I'm closer
to my mom than my dad my dad was classic
farming raised with all boys and there
was just not a lot of female energy in
there yeah and my dad did not know how
to translate that to my sister and I for
me I'm definitely I mean obviously I
walked up here I am closely with my mom
when I was a child and when my dad was
around it was the complete opposite for
me out of young age I was like 13 and I
saw him kind of go downhill you know
loss of the job gambling problem and I
was like this really ain't it yeah I
think for me I I can't really say that
I'm closer more to one than the other
just because I feel close to both of
them in different ways I'm just so
thankful for from my dad you know
because I I grew up in a predominantly
like Caucasian city with only Caucasian
friends like and my dad he came from
like a very like black background and
there were relatives that you know would
be like why does he talk like this or
you know why does he listen to that or
you know why does he walk like that or
whatever and my dad could have so easily
sided with that perspective but he was
okay with me like an R&B and rock and
you know like in there and there was
nothing wrong with that and I
love my dad for that because he made he
never made me feel like something was
wrong with me he never made me feel like
something was broke in it and and I
really really appreciate that I
hesitated just because this is this is
my dad and so he felt on the spot first
my first thought is like crap this is
going the Internet like my mom's gonna
watch it
full disclosure not trying to play
favorites or anything like that but I
was closer to my mother by default
growing up because I didn't know him
until I was 8
so our relationship was quite literally
seasonal I would spend the school years
on the East Coast in South Carolina with
my mother and then I would spend the
summers and then some holidays with him
here in Southern California so after
college we we weren't in communication
for five and a half years and we
reconnected in 2018 so were newly back
in communication within less than two
years now I wish my father showed me
more affection as my father said he
loved me in your presence he's written
it in a card he did write it in a card
was he's never said it and he's
currently 88 plus years old and you know
lot last time on his side for me it's
it's it sounds almost like really
childish but I take sometimes like I
take love is like just take my side I
don't like really want them to but I
could kind of want to do you know like I
don't want to very consistent I don't
take my wife's side on I realize that
let's get all get all the facts here I
guess I wish he was a little bit more
affectionate not in like a like oh man
like I need a I need a hook cause I'm
feeling sad but it's more like when
you're really going through that [ __ ]
like when you're 16 getting involved all
the wrong people because of the
circumstances you have to step up to and
you're doing all the bad [ __ ] like I
need you to tell me that it's gonna be
okay or like it's you know what you're
doing
it's you know it's bad but I understand
where you're doing it
maybe this will change how you know I am
doing things at the moment that's legit
just all I needed when I was like 12 to
like 17 that's that's it but that was
never got it I think it just depends on
what your love language is I think like
physical contact that just wasn't but
but I never doubted if my parents loved
me it's just like the only times we
would hug is when there was like a major
disagreement and it was so awkward like
I was like like he showed affection in
in other ways he kind of came to almost
calculated down through the different
generation gaps that generations below
me I don't you're probably right on that
cusp but yeah for men to show emotion
that was something they did not do my
dad was the farmer my mom was she had
her clothing store and she's just more
out there my dad liked to be on the
tractor and away from everybody so that
kind of immediately set the tone then
fast forward and I came out and
everything just changed you know my dad
I'm going to hell and my mom found the
love and you know just it catapult from
there so I loved seeing these 20 and 30
year olds with starting their families
and whatnot and I loved seeing the
different affections that they're able
to to put out there it's that old nomer
that men have to be this men don't cry I
love to see that being pulled away yeah
because we do yeah I need to
I think it's impactful sometimes to to
see you know like men broken down you
know because it shows the their humanity
like I've only seen my father cry twice
in my whole life
but when it did happen like it was it
was very apparent one I learned wow he
like he feels and to like it was just it
was nice for me to see that like people
aren't perfect all the time
does the impact of seeing your father
break down and cry the couple of times
you saw it it was it more impactful
because you so rarely saw it I think it
was because I didn't see it often that
it was
tactful I think there's there's a
comfort that I grew up with and knowing
that my father was strong and I'm not
saying that emotional fathers aren't but
what I am saying is is that my my dad
had a way of keeping his head in the
game at times because like if so say if
I'm emotional and my mother is emotional
and all my siblings are emotional then
like one of us has to be strong at least
that's that's what I believe and and
that doesn't mean that he's not feeling
it inside but what I love about my dad
is that he was always able to keep his
emotions under control
so is that masculinity to you sounds
like maturity I would say so yeah
yeah I would say not even just
masculinity but rank for you that's a
strength of your mother and your father
I don't want to be like my father
that's hard my father was really there
and did all the cool things what I don't
want to be like him is he was overly
emphasis on work and money and and just
less feeling oriented and to his credit
I it's just the way he was raised I
don't I don't have any bitterness toward
him for it at all yeah and I would go
along with that too just in case he does
see this because he's always been
offended by my vocal nasaan social media
and and whatnot he probably thinks I
just hate him till the cows come home
quite the opposite I respect who he is
more than he probably ever realizes he
is a honorable guy he has extremely
strong convictions and for those things
in a great work ethic so there's a lot
of great characteristics he does have
and as I get older and as I get in my
motion like wow I just so my dad I
embody more things than I thought I
would yeah what's crazy is that I really
I really attached to everything that you
said because it's like my early teenage
years like I absolutely hated my dad
like he was just there
every day not working just being there
and just kind of taking up space the
more I look into it now is as I got
older I have an understanding of why he
felt this way it's because well early on
in his life because my mom when she had
me she was only like 21 and you know
obviously with them both being young
it's like how do we do this you know for
him being the man of the house at the
time having that kind of flip to my mom
taking more responsibility I can see
where that kind of deteriorate
deteriorates him on the inside because
it's like a masculine eyes exactly you
know like you know I can't provide for
my family I can't show my son how to be
you know the ideal dad or the ideal man
or you know whatever the case is and you
know as I look back into what I was like
like I fully get it and it's like I
don't I don't hate him no because I
can't paint somebody who's literally me
and it's like his blood is running
through my veins without him there's no
me yeah even now it's I haven't even
spoken to him and maybe maybe almost six
years like at least like an actual
conversation but he'll he'll pop in like
when it's like the holidays it's
honestly it's it's a terrible feeling
but I know deep down he still cares for
both me and my sister it's just he's
lost in his own kind of way and he
doesn't know how to come back from it
which is one thing I I'm terrified first
I just want to express like how much I
appreciate your perspectives and how
much empathy you still have the capacity
to give even in the midst of the pain I
still sense that you respect your
father's to different times we didn't
speak there was a time where I was
convinced that if I had a wedding he
wouldn't show up if I had a kid he
wouldn't care and I really had to grieve
that relationship as if it was a death
in the family so to be able to have this
conversation has just been and when I
say conversation I mean it's really been
ongoing between the two of us to be able
to have that conversation has really
been a huge huge blessing man I don't
know how to say it it's just really you
know warming to have you know complete
communication
and understanding to be understood and
to understand my dad accepts the way I
live my life it's like a restart that I
was I didn't think I was gonna get being
able to just have this conversation at
all so to not only be back in
relationship but to have you know him
it's weird speaking about him and
third-person we sit across many buddy
but to have you genuinely just you know
kind of put your money where your mouth
is and say like yeah like I supports you
and really admire your passion and your
drive to do that thing now I want to
help you apply that to these areas that
you've kind of let follow the wayside
yeah see what you guys what you guys got
like now after that whole like rebuild
of everything I'm like like almost like
super jealous I know my dad even though
he he was a very vocal a lot of things I
know he was never disappointed with a
lot of the choices I made he'll be proud
that I've stepped up taking care of both
my mom my sister to the best of my
ability you know holding holding it down
at the house dude hats off to unit
that's awesome thanks seriously he never
makes me feel bad but what I am saying
is like the idea of like wanting to do
like music was something that I could
tell like took a little bit of time
because I come from a background or a
household that's like you know very like
9 to 5 like it was through my dad in his
like working endeavors that provided for
my brother and I you know and I and I
appreciate that and I'm very humbled
that you know he would he would do live
that life for me he wants you to live
that life too
well it's not it's not that I I think
that he even wants me to live that life
like it's just we're kind of just in
this waiting period like I just know I
can't be where I am right now forever
there's a few family and friend members
that constantly are kind of come on you
should talk to your dad i dude I've
never closed the door on him I mean I
came out in that early 90s which was
weird and rare then and at my age in
Colorado I knew my father wasn't really
gonna be a gung-ho cheerleader for the
gay squad but it just was surprising
when my parents divorced at how
religious he really was he's told me I'm
going to hell numerous times I said then
we're both going to hell but I'll be in
that room next door having a hell of a
lot more fun he doesn't like my smartass
quality is the tension or the lack of
communications solely based on what you
just expressed or is there anything else
that your father admires about your life
Wow did you talk to my dad no no but it
isn't interesting and it's a really
insightful question you sound like a
very successful person he seemed like a
very caring person he said you've you're
raising a son so I just wondered like if
any of that kind of like sends up a road
flare like hey like I'm not all bad or
you know like I'm doing alright I think
he would tell you I know my son's not
all bad I think in a way we both kind of
are standing there wanting to have
something more and say something do
something more but neither one of us can
find that language and that ability we
have extreme I am my father I have
extremely strong convictions and yeah
for for me it was just nice to see that
somebody has a similar situation coming
up as I did because it makes me feel
like I know what's out there
but it's nice to know that that I've met
somebody that has had a similar
experience with you know our father not
really being there a long time but it's
also good to see you guys having that
good relationship with your father and
then even you having your father here
like that's it's crazy and then even
with the the rebuild that you guys had
that's you know that's that's great to
hear to me as well and it's like I
personally I don't hear a lot of a lot
of positive things when it comes to the
things that combat me on the inside and
it's it's refreshing really is
that's it thank you so much the most
manly thing to do is not yeah we hope
you enjoyed that video a moment to like
subscribe make sure you comment below
your thoughts and if you're interested
in buying a human good face mask head
over to human good Olay calm again for
every face mask that you purchased we're
able to donate a medical-grade one for a
local healthcare professional to help us
help them we love you
stay safe and we'll see you soon
[Music]